it's being reported that President Trump
is seriously considering having the
United States buy Greenland yes
he wants to buy Greenland you didn't
know that this guy audibly shouted what
that's true that's a true thing we
didn't make that up you said that you'll
get the credit don't worry guy I'm
talking more to the audience tonight
than that God can any better no but this
is true Trump wants to buy Greenland and
a lot of people are saying it's insane
but I say maybe president Trump is on to
something maybe it's a good idea and I'm
just going to assume it is a good idea
okay so to make sure the purchase goes
through I am gonna personally travel to
Greenland as part of Conan Without
Borders
yeah thank you and here's my solemn
promise if I Conan O'Brien do not make
this deal to purchase Greenland I will
never set foot on American soil again
I hate you people Jarrett was really
into that I loving it I think this trip
to Greenland is gonna be gonna be great
uh Conan are you sure this is such a
good idea though I actually looked it up
on a map Greenland is very near the
Arctic Circle I mean you could literally
freeze your nuts off literally that's
stupid Andy you can't literally freeze
your nuts off oh really well my cousin
Eric lost both his nuts last winter and
he was in Michigan which is nowhere near
as bad as Greenland and he's actually
here tonight
isn't that right Eric yeah I lost them
back in January all it takes is a cold
night and a steel toilet seat see wait
you're saying you you don't have
testicles I have them just not with me
they're at their home in a ziplock bag
full of saltwater until science catches
up no no wait a minute wait up
I don't know why were your testicles on
the steel toilet seat wouldn't they be
between in the open space kind of
hanging in between it was late at night
I didn't turn on the light and I missed
the landing you know how if you lick a
flagpole in Alaska your tongue gets
stuck well instead of a flagpole a steel
toilet seat and instead of a tongue
Manette's
all right well Eric thank you for the
heads-up but I promise to be very
careful in fact I'll be more than
careful
I'll take along a jar of Foreman's nut
antifreeze just dunk the boys in
Foreman's antifreeze and you're good to
go so don't be like Eric use formants
Foreman's the official nut antifreeze of
komen Without Borders
you